- I just landed the new hair commercial.
I'm so sorry was that offensive?
- No.
- Know that you can always
hold me accountable.
- I like your scarf today.
- Large do rag.
- Deconstructed hoodie.
- Whatever this is, this is just so fun.
- I love your accessory.
It's really cute.
- Okay so for the team outing
we're gonna do baseball caps
is that cool with everybody?
Amal that's, we're good? That's cool?
- I mean, yeah.
- Okay cool.
Just wanted to make sure
there's no HR nightmare.
(laughing)
- Hi there I'm Aria reporting
live for channel 5 news.
Local woman found
skateboarding in her hijab.
- Hey what are you watching?
- You have to watch this, look.
- What a story,
against all odds she's
overcome so much adversity
and it's a story you'll
want to hear at 11.
Until then we're wishing her
and her family the very best
as well as a beautiful Ramadan season.
- Do you know her?
- What? No.
- Still brave.
- I was at the airport and
these two women wearing hijabs,
they were stopped by security.
So I said, like if you're gonna stop them,
you have to search me too, you know?
- What did they say when you said that?
- We were in the TSA line
so they were like you
need to wait your turn
but I realized we had a
podcast so like, time is up.
- That doesn't like really apply but yeah.
- It's insane, it's crazy.
- [Amal] It's crazy.
- [Blonde Woman] Hey.
- [Amal] Oh hey what's up?
- You know, you are so beautiful.
- Oh thank you I really appreciate that.
- But really,
- Are you okay?
- You are so beautiful.
- I love how you like always match.
- What do you mean?
- You know, you match.
- Thanks?
- You're welcome.
Hey isn't it Ramadan?
- Oh god I'm having such a bad hair day.
Oh I'm so sorry was that offensive?
- No.
- Are you sure?
- Yes.
- I didn't mean to imply that.
- It's, I have hair.
- Right.
(sighs)
- I like your hijab.
- Thank you.
(cheerful music)
- I just want to circle back
I just want to make sure like,
you're okay, I didn't mean
that my, the hair thing was,
I know it sounded weird.
- I get it.
I get it.
- [Blonde Woman] I love the weekend.